as we go into january of 1918 let's
remind ourselves of kind of the context
the background that's going on
especially relative to world war one
first of all in april of 1917 and so a
lot of the context is what happened in
1917 you have the u.s declares war on
declares war on germany and the the main
argument they give is this unrestricted
submarine warfare that the germans are
undertaking you also have the fall of
the russian empire fall of russian
russian empire you have the
essentially the revolution that
overthrows the tsar in february march of
1917 and then in october
you have the bolsheviks take over in a
coup now the fault this essentially the
bolsheviks once they take over they're
they have no interest in terms of
continuing the war with germany so you
have a an armistice declared and the
russians are in the process of
negotiating the terms of a treaty with
the central powers so they're kind of
negotiating the breslitovisk treaty as
we speak
now on top of that you have because the
central powers don't have to focus on
russia on the eastern front anymore they
are trying to
bring their especially germany is trying
to bring its troops back to the western
front and they want to do it before the
u.s can mobilize in any significant way
so race
race on western front
western front
between
essentially can germany get its troops
and do an offensive that can put
probably france out of the war before
the u.s has a chance to significantly
reinforce the western front so this is
essentially between german
remo redeployed troops from the eastern
front
german troops
troops from
eastern
from eastern front
versus new american troops versus new
americans so this is the backdrop no one
really knew what exactly was going to
happen on the western front certain
military analysts would say well like
germany was able to prosecute this
two-front war against a major empire in
russia now that they're going to be able
to focus completely on the western front
germany might be able to kind of deal
the decisive blow others would say well
look the u.s it's this it's this
emerging power it's bringing fresh
troops in it has a major industrial
capacity the u.s could if especially if
the war were to last a good bit the u.s
might make be the decisive uh decisive
element for the allies so that's the
background in which president wilson
president woodrow wilson on january of
1918 january 8th gives a speech to the
joint sessions of congress and this is a
part of the text of the speech and i'm
just going to read through it i'm not
going to read the entire speech he talks
about many things essentially why are we
in world war one what is the moral
causes of world war one and the speech
is most famous for his articulation of
the 14 points so let's just read into it
because it it really informs a lot of
what happened in the treaty of
versailles
that which is essentially the peace
treaty with germany which the u.s
ironically did not ratify
but it also kind of
lays out the the tension in in the paris
peace conferences after world war one
between those who are more idealistic
like woodrow wilson and those who might
have been a little bit more vengeful
especially against the central powers so
here we go this is part of the speech we
entered this war because violations of
right had occurred which touched us to
the quick and made the life of our own
people impossible unless they were
corrected and the world secured once for
all against their occurrence
what we demand in this war therefore is
nothing peculiar to ourselves
it is that the world be made fit and
safe to live in this is very idealistic
remember all these other especially
these european powers are all about who
gets what land who gets what empire uh
who gets to kind of uh take advantage of
whatever colony and particularly that it
be made safe for every peace loving
nation which like our own wishes to live
its own life determine its in its own
institutions and be assured of justice
and fair dealing by the other peoples of
the world as against force and selfish
aggression
all the peoples of the world are in
effect partners in this interest and for
our own part we see very clearly that
unless justice be done to others it will
not be done to us
the program of the world's peace
therefore is our program and that
program the only possible program all we
see it is this
and this is these are his 14 points and
i'll try to kind of give some context
for each of them so the first
is open covenants of peace openly
arrived at which after
after which there shall be no private
international understandings of any kind
but diplomacy shall proceed always
frankly and in the public view and the
context here is actually after the
bolsheviks took over they started
releasing all these secret these secret
covenants and understandings that the
russian empire had been getting into and
a lot of we've already talked about all
the entanglements and the alliances that
led to world war one and so this is
wilson's attempt to say hey look let's
just do everything out in the open
that'll that'll that'll let everyone
kind of know uh give more transparency
what may or may not occur based on their
actions
number two absolute freedom of
navigation upon the upon the seas
outside territorial waters alike in
peace and in war except as the seas may
be closed in whole or in part by
international action for the enforcement
of international covenants so no more of
these british blockades no more of this
unrestricted submarine warfare the only
time we could kind of dictate what
happens in in open waters is if it's the
international community trying to decide
that it wants to enforce international
covenants
number three the removal of all economic
barriers and the establishment of
equality of trade conditions among all
the nations consenting to the peace and
associating themselves for its
maintenance so essentially free trade
free
free trade number four adequate
guarantees given and taken that national
armaments will will be reduced to the
lowest point consistent with domestic
safety so he's trying to undo some of
this this militarism this this build up
this of arms that that helped
start the world
essentially allowed world war one to
happen with the ferocity that it did and
the quickness with which it did
number five a free open-minded and
absolutely impartial adjustment of all
colonial claims
based upon a strict observance of the
principle that in determining all such
questions of sovereignty the interests
of the populations concerned must have
equal weight with the equitable claims
of the government whose title is to be
determined so this is a big deal that
probably did not make the british or the
french happy this is essentially saying
look
self-determination the people who
who are in those in those nations in
those states they should be able to
their interests matter just as much so
a free open mind and absolutely
impartial adjustment of all colonial
claims so this is this is a pretty big
deal remember we're kind of exiting this
period of empires most of the european
powers still think
that these international empires are
essentially part of their their prestige
number six
the evacuation of all russian territory
and such a settlement of all questions
affecting russia as will secure the best
and freest cooperation of the other
nations of the world in obtaining for
her an unhampered and unembarrassed
opportunity for the independent
determination of her own political
development and national policy and
assure her of a sincere welcome into the
society of free nations under
institutions of her own choosing this is
still one sentence and then he doesn't
even put a period there semicolon and i
guess he had to read it himself and more
than a welcome assistance also of every
kind that she may need and may herself
desire the treatment accorded russia by
her sister nations in the months to come
remember they're negotiating with the
central powers on brexovisk to come will
be the acid test of their goodwill of
their comprehension of her needs as this
twin as distinguished from her own
interests and of their intelligent and
unselfish sympathy
so saying look i mean wilson doesn't
know whether the allies or the central
powers are going to win on the western
front but they know that the the central
powers are dictating terms to russia
with breast liftovers because it's like
look
you this is going to be a test of of
your good will of your comprehension of
the needs of this kind of newly emerging
state now that the bolsheviks have taken
over obviously at this point you don't
have the antique the antagonism between
uh the us and and the the future soviet
union that that is going to emerge
they're saying look give give russia a
chance to kind of be be be herself
number seven belgium the whole world
will agree must be evacuated and
restored without any attempt to limit
the sovereignty which she enjoys in
common with all other free nations and
so this is kind of obvious belgium when
the russian when the germans rolled
through belgium that's how they got to
france it was the justification that
great britain used for entering the war
so look get out of belgium number eight
all french territory should be freed and
the invaded portions restored and the
wrong done to france by prussia in 1871
in the matter of alsace lorraine which
has unsettled the peace of the world for
nearly 50 years should be righted in
order that peace may once more be made
secure in the interest of all so alexis
lorraine we've touched on it several
times that's
that's this region right over here it
was taken by germany as essentially the
unification of germany during the
franco-prussian war this was a
mineral-rich region this was one of the
justifications this was what why why
france might have gone into a war with
germany and what germany almost wanted
to be preemptive against france because
they were they said hey france might
want to take some of that some of that
territory back
nine a readjustment of the frontiers of
italy should be affected along clearly
recognizable lines of nationality hey
where do people speak italian number 10
the peoples of austria-hungary whose
place among the nations we wish to see
safeguard and assured should be accorded
the freest opportunity to autonomous
development so this is another big deal
it's another breaking up of an empire
it's another self-determination point of
the 14 points
austria-hungary we've already said it
was an empire it included many many many
nationalities you have the checks right
around there you have the slovaks right
around there you have the austrians
german-speaking people right right over
there you have the hungarians roughly
over there you have the slovenians
roughly over there you have the
croatians roughly over there you have
the bosnians roughly over there and i'm
you know and you have many many other
nationalities especially as you get
closer to the border with romania and
the border with the ukraine it's like
let these people determine let them
determine their own fate to some degree
there are all these nationalities
so that was number 10. the freest
opportunity to autonomous development
and it's not he's not saying that they
necessarily need their own states but
that they should have the opportunity to
kind of
self-govern in some way number 11
romania serbian montenegro should be
evacuated occupied territories restored
serbia accorded free and secure access
to the sea and the relations of the
several balkan states to one another
determined by friendly council along
historically established lines of
allegiance and nationality and
international guarantees of the
political and economic independence and
territorial integrity of the several
balkan states should be entered to and
so this is kind of laying the groundwork
for the future state of for the future
state of yugoslavia which is going to be
which is going to be roughly over there
this kind of the state of the southern
slavs which is what the whole motivation
by gravilo princip for kind of
assassinating archduke archduke
ferdinand which some would argue was
kind of the spark that lit world war one
the turkish portion of the president
ottoman empire should be assured a
secure sovereignty
but the other nationalities which are
now under turkish rule should be assured
in undoubted security of life and an
absolutely unmolested opportunity of
autonomous development once again
self-determination and the dardanelle
should be permanently opened as a free
passage to the ships to the ships and
commerce of all nations under
international guarantees so the
dardanelles we've talked about it before
that is that's this right over here so
that you have access between the aegean
sea
and the black sea
and we are almost there so then you have
an independent polar state should be
erected an independent polar state
should be erected which should include
the territories inhabited by the
indisputably polish populations which
should be assured of free and secure
access to the sea and whose political
and economic independence and
territorial integrity should be
guaranteed by international covenant so
poland did not exist as its own state
prior to world war one
now you have woodrow wilson is
advocating it and it will be carved out
roughly of this area right over there
then finally
finally point 14 a general association
of nations must be formed under specific
covenants for the purpose of affording
mutual guarantees of political
independence and territorial integrity
to great and small stakes states alike
so this is essentially this is the point
that leads to the formation of the
league of nations and this is a when we
talk about big ideas this is a big idea
especially back then you have this
europe that keeps getting into wars with
each other hey why don't we all
cooperate cooperate at this kind of meta
level and and we have this this this
this club of all of the nations to kind
of resolve disputes and and you know and
and and make sure that we don't have
another world war one so very very very
big very very big idealistic idea it
gets formed during the treaty or as an
outcome of the treaty of versailles
which which is radical urges which is
drafted during the paris peace
conferences after world war one the
unfortunate thing of the league of
nations is that even though this was
kind of the idea it was coming from
woodrow wilson
the the treaty of versailles and the
league of nations was was not ratified
by the u.s so the u.s never entered the
league of nations which kind of made it
a little bit hollow
and the league of nations did not have
the power to stop world war ii from
happening only only only a few decades
only a few decades later and it will
later be replaced by the united nations
but this is a really really really
really really big idea and because of
these big ideas
woodrow will send these very idealistic
ideas i mean you know everyone in europe
is talking about territory and
imperialism and how do they how do they
take control of other people take
control of their resources and now you
have the american president say look
it's all about self-determination it's
about making the world safe for
democracy safe for commerce about open
about open agreement so it's a very
powerful idea and this would kind of
form the basis kind of the more
idealistic side of american foreign
policy over the 20th century some would
say that there's another very cynical
side that takes
into account self-interest but this is
this is the the idealistic side of
american foreign policy especially
through the 20th century and for this
for his work in this in this area
woodrow wilson wins the nobel prize a
few years later so this right here is a
picture of what the nobel prize looks
like both sides of it
now and just to kind of foreshadow some
of the tension as we get into the paris
peace conference not everyone was as
idealistic you obviously have these
european powers who bled much harder
than the americans did although the
americans did have
did contribute significant cost or you
know troops to the effort and they lost
many many many folks but obviously if
you're french you had these germans
on your territory you lost a significant
fraction of your population a huge
fraction of your male population you
might be a little bit angrier and so of
course you have george clemenceau who
was the prime minister of france and and
he was a little bit more skeptical of
the 14 points this is a quote from him
he has actually has many slightly
entertaining quotes
mr wilson bores me with his 14 points
why god almighty has only 10. and this
will kind of this foreshadows some of
the tension between clem and so
the and and the british and and kind of
the the european allies on one side and
the americans as we go into the paris
peace conference they were a little bit
looking out more for revenge especially
against the germans while the americans
especially woodrow wilson was a little
was actually a lot more idealistic